we are open for dialogue NATO does not
seek confrontation we do not want a new
Cold War we continue to strive for a
more constructive and more cooperative
relationship with Russia and that's what
we do partly by our military operation
but partly by keeping channels for
political dialogue open addressing many
different issues on the Iran nuclear
deal or trying to reach or implement an
agreement on cessation of hostilities in
Syria dialogue is not a sign of weakness
dialogue is a sign of self-confidence
turkey is the ally and the NATO ally
most affected by the crisis the violence
the turmoil in Syria and Iraq NATO will
not turn back the boats we will not do
police activities in the agency we will
help local authorities meaning the
Turkish Coast Guard the Greek Coast
Guard the front X to do their job we
will not to do to the job for them then
all nations are obliged all vessels
wherever they come from are obliged to
help those people and of course that all
surprise for NATO vessels then we will
rescue the people and what we agreed
with turkey at the Defense Ministry on
meeting was that if the people who are
rescued by NATO if they come from Turkey
we can return them to Turkey